foreign
modern day wheat lines
that have a special ability
to produce large amounts of foam
antibiotics from the root systems
you may be wondering
why do we need antibiotics from the
wheat root systems
you only take antibiotics
when you are sick isn't it
the agricultural systems the modern
farming systems have become
increasingly sick lately
they are so sick that nearly 70 percent
of the nitrogen fertilizers that are
being applied to farmlands are being
leaked out
the leaking nitrogen uncontrollably
if you look at the nitrogen fertilizer
consumption
from the beginning of Green Revolution
it has grown nearly 30 fold
from 5 million metric tons
in the beginning of Green Revolution
250 million metric tons what we are
currently using
a 30-fold increase in nitrogen
fertilizer consumption
has resulted in a four-fold increase in
global food grain production
of course we all know that
Green Revolution has transformed the
global food grain production
saved us from
family food secure from the food
scarcities
and provided the global food security
but you have to ask yourself
a 34 increase in nitrogen fertilizer
consumption
is supporting only four-fold increase
in food grain production could increase
what's happening
when you apply nitrogen fertilizers it
is mostly in ammonium form
ammonium form
binds the soil
doesn't move
doesn't create any harmful nitrogen
byproducts there's no problem with
ammonium nitrogen but there is a little
bacteria lives in the soil
that started eating away this fertilizer
nitrogen ammonium
and spitting it out into nitrate
and also it's making many
other harmful nitrogen byproducts
the problem with night the nitrate is
though many plants can use nitrates as
nitrogen source
but
nitrogen cannot bind to the soil
it washes out
if you have rain
if you have irrigation it washes out
from the farmlands
that is the problem
this little bacteria used to be a small
subdued microbial activity in the
overall biological the soil biological
activity has grown now into a monster
it's consuming nearly 95 to 99 percent
of the fertilizer nitrogen and spitting
it out into nitrates
we should be asking are we fertilizing
our crops are we fertilized in this
little bacteria which we have helped
it to grow into a a big monster
this is what happens
when the nitrogen moves into water
streams
pollutes legs
triggers algal blooms and creates
another Green Revolution
if you don't keep the nitrogen in
farmlands
if it if you allow it to move into the
water bodies and to the larger ecosystem
it creates another Green Revolution in a
ecologically destructive way
if you look at the soil
it's a living biological system
an invisible
microbial world
there's a large microbial universe
operating in these soil systems they are
involved in
numerous functions breaking down
everything
into individual components nourishing
our crops to grow and produce food
it's so complex it's much much bigger
than the ecosystem what we know
that the ecosystem above the ground
what we know it's much more complex
just to give you an example a gram of
soil would have about 10 billion
microbial cells
10 billion microbes in a gram of soil
doing various functions it's much larger
than the entire human population what
you see on Earth
this is a microbial this microbial
universe is affected affected so
severely from the last seven decades of
Green Revolution
particularly the infusion of large
amounts of nitrogen fertilizers
caused disruption to this microbial
activity and change the population
Dynamics as I said what used to be a
small
insignificant micro the microbial
activity in the soils has grown into
a monstrous proportions
sucking up all the fertilizer nitrogen
what we are applying
Nature has evolved many solutions to
some of the problems we are facing in
agriculture and some of the problems we
are going to create and face in future
what you see is over there
is a black era tropical pasture grass
it grows extensively
in South America
it has a unique ability it produces
large amounts of antibiotics from the
root systems these antibiotics are
specifically directed at
this little bacteria we say the
nitifying bacteria
because of that it's it's tightly
controls this nitrifying bacteria
function in the soil it doesn't allow it
to function it doesn't kill that
bacteria but it doesn't allow to
function
just to keep them in a kind of comma
state
because of that
you don't see any kind of nitrate
formation in these
tropical facets in the particular this
tropical plastic glass and also you
don't see any nitrogen nitrogen gas
emitted from this
passes no night the subset is emitted
from these facets because it controls
this bacteria so tightly by producing
large amounts of antibiotics from the
root systems
the question is
how do we bring this kind of ability
into our crop plants
most of our food production
comes from four crops
wheat Maize rice and sogum these are the
four crops that provide the global food
security almost 80 to 90 percent of the
food grains are produced from these four
crops and also these four crops consume
more than 90 percent of the entire
nitrogen fertilizer produced
industrially goes to these four
production systems
they don't this this these food crops
the staple crops don't have much ability
that's the reason they are leaking
so
if you look at this you see the wild
wheat
it has the ability to produce 20 to 30
times antibiotics from the root systems
our group has worked in the last 15
years to try and relocate the genomic
region responsible for producing these
antibiotics and transfer to the
cultivated weight we have done it you
see that
the oranges orange is a part of the
chromosome that is coming from the wild
wheat
which is coding the antibiotics so we
have we have got it got that integrated
with the weed genome
without disrupting the the elite
architecture of the wheat system and
also without disrupting the yield the
yield potential and without
interfering with the bread making
quality of the wheat
these new category of which we call
benavids the weeds that can produce
large amounts of antibiotics from the
root systems to control this bacteria so
that they can control the nitrate
production in the root systems
because of this
the night is in fertilizer whatever we
are applying would stay in the root Zone
doesn't leak look at the the BNI weeds
well it looks quite healthy and green
you see the the right side that is the
current modern weights which leaks out
all the nitrogen whatever we have
applied the both the both the plots were
applied from the same amount of nitrogen
exactly the same time
in one case it leached out in the other
case it remained in the in the in in the
farmlands these are the bnabis these are
the Next Generation which on the
development so in a few years from now
they will be available to the farmers so
our hope is in the next 10 next 10 years
most of the weeds that are grown in
different parts of the world would have
this kind of ability so that the
nitrogen leakage can be stopped by
infusing these large amount of
antibiotic antibiotics from the root
systems that that's what is going to
control that's what is going to reduce
the amount of nitrogen fertilizers in
future in which in wheat root systems
thank you
[Applause]